Що все це каже нам про екологію в Німеччині?
У Німеччини досить "зелена" репутація.
Відомо, що німці люблять природу. Але чи добре вони її охороняють?
Я сортую сміття.
Сортую все, що може бути перероблене.
Сміття сортую, як усі в Німеччині. А ще у мене немає машини.
Користуюся велосипедом, купую органічні, регіональні та сезонні продукти.
У мене холодильник енергоефективний.
Я став веганом.
Купую менше пластикових упаковок.
Каву з собою беру без пластикових кришечок. Про такі дрібниці я раніше не думав, зате тепер зрозумів.
Галузь загальнодержавного значення - переробка відходів.
Цим Німеччина нерідко дивує іноземців. Пляшки здають як тару або кидають у вуличні контейнери для скла.
Правила сортування варіюються за складністю в різних містах.
Німці суворо стежать за розділенням сміття і повчають своїх недбайливих сусідів.
Але не все так гладко. За деякими даними, половина відходів у різних контейнерах для ресайклінгу для них не призначена.
А дві третини побутового сміття можна було б переробити.
У підсумку, незважаючи на сортування, більше полов ини відходів у Німеччині, як і раніше, спалюється.
Ще краще було б створювати менше відходів. Але Німеччина досі - один з найбільших виробників сміття на душу населення в ЄС.
Німеччина підписала Паризьку угоду - міжнародний договір про стримування зростання глобального потепління нижче 2° C
у порівнянні з доіндустріальним періодом.
У 2020 році Німеччина виконала свої зобов'язання зі скорочення викидів вуглекислого газу -
багато в чому завдяки зниженню попиту на енергію через пандемію. А звідки Німеччина бере енергію?
У 2019-му джерелами електроенергії були: 30% вугілля, 15% газ, 12% атом та 40% відновлювані джерела, з них половина - енергія вітру.
Але це лише струм. Якщо враховувати транспорт і опалення, то частка відновлюваних джерел падає нижче 20%,
і на перший план повертається викопне паливо.
Видобуток вугілля має в Німеччині давні традиції. Шахтарським регіоном була Рурська область.
Вона відіграла величезну роль в індустріалізації Німеччини.
Своє та імпортне вугілля десятиліттями було важливим джерелом енергії.
Але його репутація останнім часом зіпсувалася через високі викиди CO2 і руйнування природних ландшафтів під час його видобутку.
Взяти до прикладу Гамбахський ліс, якому понад 12 тисяч років. Від його первісної території і так залишилася лише восьма частина -
усе через видобуток бурого вугілля. Але нещодавно ліс знову постав перед загрозою.
Як врятувати ліс? Побудувати на дереві будинок і заселити його! Так і зробили активісти-екологи.
І вони перемогли! Уряд Німеччини взяв під охорону те, що залишилося від Гамбахського лісу.
Повністю відмовитися від вугілля німці планують до 2038 року.
Але що прийде йому на зміну? Деякі індустріальні країни роблять ставку на ядерну енергетику на шляху до скорочення викидів CO2.
Але після ядерної катастрофи в Японії у 2011 році німецькі політики вирішили припинити виробляти атомну енергію в Німеччині до 2022 року.
Проміжним рішенням міг би стати природний газ. Але у Німеччині власних запасів газу мало.
Ось тут і виникають суперечки через будівництво газопроводу з Росії до Німеччини.
У довгостроковій перспективі Німеччина планує перейти на відновлювані джерела і виробляти енергію за допомогою вітру, сонця і води.
Аби забезпечити 65% електроенергії з відновлюваних джерел до 2030 року, потрібно терміново модернізувати енергосистему країни.
Також висловлювалася критика, що за перехід на відновлювані джерела енергії, по суті, платять споживачі.
Адже струм у Німеччині - один з найдорожчих у світі!
План переходу на відновлювані джерела не продумали належним чином.
Дорогі бензин і електрика тягарем лягають на плечі простих людей.
Який сенс відключати власні атомні електростанції, а потім купувати ядерну енергію у Франції?
Занадто повільно ми відмовляємося від вугілля.
Дуже мляво. Така ж ситуація з будь-якими інноваціями в нашій країні.
Збитки хочуть скоротити і зберегти робочі місця в певних галузях, але хтось неминуче постраждає.
Рух Fridays for Future бореться вже два роки, і вони роблять дуже багато.
До пандемії майже третина німецьких школярів виходили на страйк під егідою Fridays for Future.
Тобто, головний ініціатор охорони клімату в Німеччині - молодь?
Настав момент, коли я подумала: "Дорослі, уряди, концерни, ті, хто ухвалює рішення, мабуть, не розуміють, що відбувається!
Тоді ми повинні змусити їх говорити про це і діяти. Ми - багата і процвітаюча країна, і ми собі можемо багато чого дозволити.
Але розплачуватися будуть люди в інших частинах світу або в майбутньому, наприклад, моє покоління.
Якби не шкільні страйки, ніхто б не заговорив про кліматичну кризу.
А тепер клімат - це тема, яку вже ніхто в Німеччині не може ігнорувати.
Щоб виправдати свою "зелену" репутацію, Німеччині потрібно ще розібратися зі своєю автозалежністю.
З 2010 по 2019 рік автомобілів у Німеччині стало більше на 12%.
У німецького автопрому величезні доходи, сотні тисяч працівників і потужне політичне лобі.
Дизельний скандал 2015 року, коли концерн VW був викритий у маніпуляції програмним забезпеченням з виміру шкідливих вихлопів,
змусив автовиробників замислитися про екологію.
І хоча німецькі компанії не відразу визнали необхідність електричного транспорту,
в 2021 році, за прогнозами, вони побудують найбільше електромобілів у світі.
Потім потрібно буде поліпшити інфраструктуру для електромобілів по всій країні.
Щоб відучити німців від їхніх улюблених машин, потрібні доступний і надійний громадський транспорт, а також більше доріжок для велосипедистів.
Деякі міста вже йдуть цим шляхом. На черзі - вся країна.
То чи заслуговує Німеччина свою "зелену" репутацію? Напишіть, що ви думаєте.